we lost a comedian about a week ago
and i don't want to talk out of school
he struggled man this guy struggled at a
level that was um man he struggled
i think he was the
he he was one of the two funniest people
i'd ever seen on stage
kill a crowd or him
and joey diaz kill a crowd
actually i'll add in i'll add in
crystallia and i'll add in earthquake
um kill
really kill a crowd and uh
and his name is eric myers and he
um
and i just say this because i want i
just want his name to be said and i want
it to be heard
and uh he died in texas
a week ago he um apparently
relapsed and uh was walking on the
freeway or the interstate late at night
and was hit by a vehicle
a van actually jesus oh
i i getting hit by a car sounds away
actually are getting hit by a vanta
both sound bad actually car sounds worse
i think than van
because van like it's all you know one
point of kind of
um but uh
you know he was supposed to come on here
a couple months ago he was in memphis
five weeks ago maybe he was in memphis
and we were messaging and he was gonna
come here to
be a guest on the podcast and i said
don't come man like it's just i felt bad
he was gonna have to come
you know four hours or something i think
he was taking the bus
and i just said we'll do it later we'll
do it when i'm down near you in florida
where he lived
um
and it just bums me out like i just
i i don't know maybe if i had been in a
space where i was just more like
yes yes saying yes to things you know or
just
maybe if my spirits have been hired that
day not that i would have saved him or
done anything but we just would have had
a time you know he just
maybe there would have been one extra
moment of somebody saying yes
i care you know welcome
come in you know be a part
of uh
so
man he struggled man he has so many
hilarious stories i hope to one day get
someone in here who knows a lot of the
stories
of eric myers um
he had a unique voice hollywood missed
him
they they missed him
he was just i mean he was from another
planet
i would see him in baton rouge we would
work together we worked together down in
florida captain brian's off the hook
and you gotta do comedy and they're
doing cracking their [ __ ]
oysters and slaughtering uh octopus or
octopi right next to you
you [ __ ] telling a joke and they're
[ __ ] telling an octopus his last
rites you know
they're over there electric electric
chair and clams and you trying to rattle
off a riddle you know
and we had to switch each time and we
had he one of us would go first one was
go second i did not want to go second
i did not want to go second because that
means i had to go after him
and he came down to baton rouge once and
i would see him in texas
uh anyway he's just really talented
sorry i'm just kind of rambling and just
kind of lamenting at the same time
um but i hope you go check out his stuff
he has a special on youtube
that was i think shot at the laugh
factory or somewhere um
but man he was so good
but man he battled with the devil
i mean he just had it inside of him
so anyway sorry to be such a downer look
i'm sorry to be the down here
but brady how do i stay i just the only
thing that i know
which hasn't always kept me sober but it
has kept me alive
is that i try to communicate with others
um
and contrary action you don't feel like
doing something do it
you don't do it that's the thing you'll
surprise yourself then you'll realize
how much you're capable of
but i'm not trying to preach at you man
i love you bro and keep your head up dog
and um praise god man gang [ __ ]
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one